ce soir je m'adresse à vous parce que
j'ai un problème à résoudre à savoir je
sois depuis six mois avec un homme marié
que j'aime et que j'aimerai pouvoir
continuer à voir j'ai eu l'occasion il
ya peu de temps une personne de joueurs
environ de rencontrer sa femme avec
laquelle j'ai beaucoup sympathisé et
elle est devenue une amie à moi et je
suis très gêné avec cette relation et
cette nouvelle amitié je ne sais pas
quoi faire dites moi ce que je dois
faire et des mois vous avez bien raison
d'être gêné parce que quand on aime un
homme marié il faut mieux ne pas
connaître sa femme on risque tout
simplement de les voir se réconcilier et
se fâche et tous les deux avec vous mais
en somme vous avez le choix
ou vous gardez le mari qu'au moment où
vous gardez la femme comme ami moi si
c'était vous je garderai la femme parce
qu'une bonne amie c'est beaucoup plus
rare qu'un bon amant surtout jolie comme
vous êtes
voici mon problème je rentre le soir je
suis crevé je j'ai pas tellement envie
d'être à côté ma femme elle pourtant
elle adore faire l'amour le soir mais
c'est je suis tellement fatigué que je
ne peux pas ce n'est que comme atteint
que je suis informé que bon c'est plutôt
pour elle le matin mois elle pense qu
aux gamins quelle qu'elles fassent le
ménage qu'elle s'occupe de diptyque et
qu'elle ramène à l'école et tous
n'appelle temps pour moi alors moi c'est
le mois où j'ai jamais envie alors
qu'est ce que je fais ce choix de qu'est
ce que je dois faire
vous me racontez une nouvelle version du
veilleur de nuit et de la femme de
journée qu'est ce que vous faites de 6
fatigant pour être aussi fatigué le soir
bon mettons vous êtes fatigués et vous
savez que les femmes le matin elles ont
beaucoup de choses à faire et puis elle
n'aime pas ces élans masculin qui leur
paraissent un peu trop physiologique est
pas tout à fait assez amoureux
elles se sentent un petit peu gadget et
croyez moi une femme n'aime pas du tout
être réveillé
et par un menton râpeux sur son sternum
alors devriez faire un accord elle est
trop prise le matin vous êtes trop
fatigué l'après midi pourquoi ne pas
vous donner rendez-vous après le
déjeuner après la vaisselle
j'aurai tout le temps c'est comprendre
depuis un certain temps qui me trompe
pas vengeance je sors un soir avec son
meilleur ami
finalement je me suis laissé prendre au
piège
j'aime son ami j'aime aussi mon mari
qu'est ce que je dois faire
ils sont si différents l'un de l'autre
est ce qu'il est possible d'aimer deux
hommes à la fois je ne veux pas quitter
mon mari ni mon ami ni son ami est-ce
que vous priez le conseiller a je vous
comprends n'y a rien de plus merveilleux
que d'aimer deux hommes à la fois
malheureusement c'est un bonheur qui ne
peut pas durer longtemps
sinon on risque de se trouver tout seul
parce que l'un et l'autre finissent par
se fâcher alors consomme votre mari vous
a laissé entendre qu'il vous trompait
mais vous ne lui avait rien fait savoir
sur le fait que vous le trompiez vous
n'avez pas tout à fait tard parce que
quand les hommes trompent leur femme
considère que c'est une petite affaire
sans importance alors que quand c'est la
femme mon dieu quelle horreur
vous devriez quand même finir par lui
dire parce qu'il vaut mieux avouer que
de se faire prendre
alors si votre mari est quelqu'un de
deux gentils de calme d'équilibré dites
lui dites lui que en somme vous avez
fait ce qu'il a fait est que pendant
qu'ils s'amusent ailleurs il est
légitime que vous vous amusiez de votre
côté et que d'eux mêmes qu'ils vous
aiment beaucoup tout en nous trompant
vous tenez beaucoup à lui tout en le
trompant mais si c'est un grand nerveux
capable de se livrer à des voies de fait
et à de grands drames
alors demandez plutôt à votre ami et aux
siens de lui faire cet aveu
parce que devant les hommes les autres
hommes se conduisent avec beaucoup plus
désinvolture et de tranquillité
évidemment votre risque c'est que votre
mari préfère garder un copain fides
qu'une épouse qui se venge
oui